under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
So I'm hoping you
will ask some questions today.
So we've had the exam.
If you have any questions
about grading the two TAs
are the people to speak to.
Ramis graded Questions
one and two, and Peter
graded three and four.
And they control things.
I mean, I can help if
there's an emergency,
but they would be the
right people to speak to.
Because they know how they
graded the whole test.
Before you ask questions, can
I just say why this truss --
you remember this
six-sided truss --
tied me in a knot and I'm hoping
your MATLAB solution will untie
that knot.
The knot I was in was to
find the mechanisms, to find
convenient mechanisms
because we have,
well, I thought we had six bars.
It looks like we have six bars.
But somebody pointed
out after class
that that bar six
is not very active.
It's connecting two
supports, can't do anything,
and actually that sixth
row of the A matrix
will be all zeroes.
So our matrix, if we include
that, there was no use,
it doesn't help.
So our matrix then really
comes from the five bars,
so A is then five by, two
unknowns, two, two, two,
making altogether
eight unknowns.
So three mechanisms and
that's what I'm hoping for.
So when I unwisely drew
that picture on the board
at the end of the truss
lecture, I was only
looking for two
mechanisms because I
was thinking we had
six edges, six bars,
but really this bar,
when I knock out
the columns that correspond
to that node and that node,
there will only be
zeroes left in that row.
And it's nothing.
It correctly tells us that the
stretching of that bar is zero
but we knew that anyway.
OK, I don't know if you've
tackled the MATLAB question,
and I also don't know whether
MATLAB would produce for us--
I mean, you should
be able to construct
A with a whole lot of
square roots of three
over two from sine of 60
degrees and maybe 1/2's
from sine of 30 degrees.
A should look pretty nice, but
what the solutions to these
mechanisms are, of
course solutions to Au=0,
and-- Anyway, I'm hoping that
we learn from this example.
I hadn't intended-- So
it's pretty small MATLAB,
it's really just the
creation of the matrix A.
OK, so that was a
comment on that,
which I added to the homework.
Now, I'm ready for questions
about the homework, the exam
whatever, yes thank you.
Oh, good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
For trusses, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
A^T A immediately, couldn't you?
It's not quite so
straightforward.
And this is like more realistic.
I mean, yeah.
Ah.
I guess, yeah, but remind
me what that question was.
This was a 2.7 problem one?
OK, let me just see
what I'm asking for.
So, OK, yes.
So I only asked
about A transpose A,
I only asked you for the
shape in that question.
Oh, and then I asked you for
the first row, good for me, yes.
I see, the first row
so I didn't put you
to the agony of writing
out the whole thing,
but still how do you get the
first row, good question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh, I see.
Now, well it's not
going to be so neat.
Let's just think.
We could do the first row of
A, and the first column of A
probably, yeah.
So what am I looking
for in A transpose A,
because it didn't say row one.
OK, so row one of A transpose A
corresponds to the first-- Oh,
so what is row one?
Yeah, this is worth
thinking about.
So this is A transpose
A for trusses.
And let's just,
maybe we could even
take this one as an example.
If I number the nodes, if that's
my first node, A transpose A,
you remember that's square.
That tells us the edge part,
the bar part is built into it.
But its size is n by n, its
size is five by, no, its size
is what, eight by eight, right?
It's got to do with
the number of-- OK.
So its first row, what will
its first row be about?
It'll be about u H 1, right?
The first row of
this A transpose
A matrix will be about, the
first node but more than that,
that node has got two
things, u H and u V,
and we're putting H first.
So so I think that the first
row of this, let's just draw it.
Maybe I'm not saying--
So let that be A
transpose A, I see, yeah.
A transpose A will be
multiplying u H 1, u V 1,
and so forth.
Right?
OK, good.
So now this is better.
All I'm asking is
where do we know
there are zeroes in that
first row of A transpose A?
Where would we know that there
are zeroes for this problem
rather than-- I won't
redraw the one in the book
so I'm taking this truss.
So if it's this truss,
this is the first node,
the bars are numbered like
this, and of course your MATLAB
construction of A, you might
multiply out A transpose A.
Because in MATLAB that
would be so quick.
And you could see
what it looks like.
And where would we expect
to see zeroes or not zeroes?
Let's see, A transpose
A, so I'll have to think.
My instinct is that it should
only connect two neighbors.
So that I would
imagine, but I've
got-- These are
double neighbors,
right, there's two
people living here.
We have to remember.
So I see two people living
here and two people at home,
so I guess I would imagine four
non-zeroes for this problem
in in the first row.
I would think that that would
have somebody on the diagonal.
That would be what
multiplies u H 1 itself,
and then maybe u V 1 is
involved, and these two guys.
These two and those two
would not be involved.
Well, that's only
a partial answer,
I'm just telling you where
the zeroes are, I think.
And you're really asking about
the non-zeroes, of course.
So, yeah.
Not so easy.
Yeah --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: --
maybe have to do it.
OK, yeah.
I think, the first time
better to do it, yeah.
But that's an
excellent question,
and maybe we will find a
nice, and if somebody does,
let me know.
A nice way to see that.
Somehow I must have
felt that was doable
when I created that problem.
OK.
The other thing to say
though, that while I'm
looking at A transpose
A, is remember
that it can be created by
these element matrices.
Yeah, yeah, that's
important to say.
So there will be five
element matrices, right?
Because I've got five bars.
And the element matrix
for this bar, or say
for a typical bar, the
element matrix for this bar
will involve all the u's that
are connected to this bar.
So two u's there
and two u's there,
so it'll be four by four,
the element matrix here.
So this will contribute four
non-zeroes to that to row
and to three other rows.
That four by four guy
from this part is,
you know what I'm
speaking about here?
The element matrix which is
just-- The element matrix
is a cosine, sine, minus
cosine and minus sine.
Column times row.
Cosine, sine, minus
cosine, minus sine.
This is the element
matrix for this bar,
those are the cosine
and sine of 60 degrees,
and those positions would
be these two and these two.
So there would be actually four
zeroes coming after, and after
here from those
two and those two.
So this bar contributes
to A transpose A,
sort of stamps
into A transpose A.
This four by four of non-zeroes
plus the rest zeroes, stamps
that in up there.
This guy has its
own element matrix.
Now, what's different about the
element matrix for this guy?
Of course it's got its own c_1,
probably, and it had a c_2,
this difference constant.
But bigger
differences than that.
First of all, it's a
different angle, theta.
Here the angle is 120
degrees, and also there's
nobody home down there.
So it would be, if we
were dealing with A_0,
free-free stuff, it
would be four by four,
like all the others.
But because these two are
fixed, those two displacements
are fixed, effectively it will
only contribute two by two.
A total of four non-zeroes.
But those will stamp
into A transpose
A overlapping this guy.
Then the ones from
these bars will not
touch the first row
of A transpose A,
so they wouldn't
touch the answer
to that homework problem.
So you see again another way.
By hand, I don't know
that you necessarily
want to use these element
matrices, I'm not sure.
But it gives an excellent check.
So one way to
create A transpose A
is create a-- Multiply,
that's one way.
Second way is, create A
transpose A element by--
By these five element matrices
popped into the right places.
I think this is, so this like
the computational science
part of the course.
It's the way you
would, I'm really
speaking about the way you
would write the code, not
the final result. So,
much of the course
has been devoted to
understanding A transpose A,
and the fact that it's
positive definite,
or in this case only positive
semi-definite because we
have an eight by eight
matrix whose rank is only
going to be five.
So this matrix will have
these same mechanisms,
and I'm hoping to
learn what they are.
Well I hope that's a little
help with that question.
But basically,
though, it's non-help
because I'm sort of
saying you're on your own
to actually-- I don't have
a superfragilistic way
to construct a matrix and then
you kind of have to do it.
But I'm glad you asked.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: More
on this problem, OK.
The sign convention.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yes.
So let's see.
So I made a speech about
sign conventions, right?
Which was that I am
too old for them.
And the justification
for that is the fact
that they wash out
in A transpose.
So if you were to use the
wrong sign convention in A,
you won't see it
in A transpose A.
So if I change the whole thing.
So sign convention is
not really a convention.
Our convention is to decide that
that movement that way is plus.
And movement this way is plus.
And here, similarly.
That's a plus movement and
that's a plus movement.
That's our sign convention.
If we always do that,
then the A matrix
is telling us how much
this bar stretches.
It's the matrix that gives
us stretching from these four
displacements.
And then, these, I
think in this picture,
if this is the later node
and this is the thing,
then that angle
from the horizontal
is the right guy to put there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Here?
PROFESSOR STRANG: Well,
I guess I'm, I see,
the question is what's
the sign convention
with this particular picture?
Yeah, if this is node
one and that's two,
then-- Your question is good.
It looks, I think, so I
think I've got it not right.
If this is node one down
below, and two up above,
then moving two positively
would stretch the bar.
And I've got minuses there.
So I've got the opposite signs.
I've got there, the signs that
would go with this numbering.
If that was node two
and this was node one.
Yeah, you're right, good.
You have to, and that's
the only way I do it,
is to think will the
movement stretch the bar?
Then that's got a
positive entry in A. Will
the movement like that
compress the bar, that'll
be a negative entry.
And our conventions are if
it stretches that's positive.
e positive means a stretching;
e negative means a compression.
So it takes a little patience.
Or it takes writing
the code correctly once
and then of course it would
do it for all these problems.
Yeah, I think the TA
in an earlier year
actually wrote a code
to, a truss code.
I don't know what happened
to it but I could look.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yes, yeah.
That's right, and it
will come out consistent.
Yeah, if I take horizontal-- if
I take the same convention that
forces that way are plus,
that's a plus f H 1,
and it's a plus u H 1, then I'll
get A will go to A transpose.
Yeah, so if I'm consistent
that plus for the u's,
for the displacements, and
plus for the f's, forces,
then the correctly created
A will give me the correct A
transpose.
But A transpose
A has the ability
to bury some of
those conventions.
OK.
Good.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Different.
More.
Oh my God.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
This one, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
PROFESSOR STRANG: I wish it
would ask about bar three.
Yeah, yeah bar three was good.
Yeah right.
Yeah, I guess here, what's here,
well, the angle is, that must
be theta, and then
this'll be right provided
this number is the, is what?
Well, I've got to
think it out again.
I'll just think it out.
Maybe, yeah I won't
try to, yeah I won't.
I won't.
So I think you--
But it's really,
you learn the point by
thinking that through.
I think we've got it here.
That if that's number one
then we like plus signs here
because positive displacements
will stretch the bar, right.
And here this sign will
depend on the angle.
And it will depend on the
number, which numbers,
what number that one is and
what number that one is.
If I reverse the numbers,
then I reverse the sign.
Yeah, good.
Well, that's sort of part
of computational engineering
isn't it?
Like, keep track of the details.
But of course this
18.085 course is also
about big picture things.
And that's what I'm hoping
comes through even better.
OK, ready for another
question on any topic.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yes.
Well, no, but let's just try it.
Shall we do Problem one?
Was it Problem one?
In 2.7?
OK, let me just draw that truss.
And let's just talk about it.
So, boy I've put a
lot of bars in there.
OK, so this is just one
bar down to this guy.
And this is one up to here.
And was that everything?
OK, and then I've numbered them.
Let me just copy
the number here,
so that we can talk about that.
And I numbered the
nodes one, two.
One.
Joints, I should say really.
Four.
OK, all right.
Let's just start
as I always do by,
what's the shape
of the matrix A?
A is what, how many
bars have I got?
So help me through this now.
Six bars, and how many unknown
displacements have I got?
Eight, OK, good.
And have I got any
rigid motions here?
No.
I've got two, these are going to
prevent all the rigid motions.
So if this matrix, if A has
rank six, which we'd probably
guess it has, you know
that there's an if there.
Then two mechanisms, right?
Eight minus six
gives two mechanisms.
OK, and your question
is how to find them.
You've got one.
Alright, which one have you got?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: These guys.
So tilt, so that's a mechanism
that only involves u H 1 and u
H 2 and none of the other u's.
OK, that looks good.
So that's certainly one.
Now we're looking
for a second one.
What if, anybody suggest one?
Let me just give
everybody a thought.
If you haven't already
started on this homework,
you're starting now.
So I'm looking for
another mechanism,
and of course you
might say well,
suppose these bars go this way.
Suppose they go to
the left, and you
know that that's not
going to do it right.
And why not?
Why isn't that an
OK second answer?
Because it's effectively the
same as the first; in fact
the mechanism u, how would
the u, the one I've drawn
and the u for this
way, what would we see?
Opposite signs.
If this describes a u 1
H and a u 2 H positive,
the other way
they're negative, it
would just be the opposite
sign, nothing new.
OK, so now you've had
a look, so tell me.
If somebody sees-- To
answer your question here,
how do you see them?
I don't know.
Just look harder.
Like you know, speaking French.
Just say it louder
and maybe it'll work.
Of course we do
have the possibility
to create the matrix
and look for solutions.
But it's more fun
to do it this way.
And now who's going to
suggest another mechanism,
another view?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Three and four.
Wait a minute, what
was that three?
Oh, these nodes, OK.
These nodes, three
and four do what?
Oh yes, sorry.
Three go up this way.
Ah, I see.
You're rotating.
So this guy goes sort
of along this way,
you're taking that top
square and turning it.
OK, so these guys
will also turn, right?
Yeah, one and two will
move on your mechanism.
So the idea is take
that top thing,
and I'm allowed to turn it,
I'd say I have to turn it,
I have to keep this bar,
yeah I cannot stretch it.
I can't stretch any bars.
So when I do this turn, I can't
just keep it in place and turn.
No.
But I'm going to turn
it so that this one goes
this way and this one
goes this way, and now.
Alright you're, you're
responsible for telling me
about the other two now.
What do they do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Bar four,
Will bar four keep its length?
Ha.
OK, well we're not
allowed to use fancy words
like four-bar linkage.
Because somebody might
say what does that mean.
OK, does it, do you see that?
I think it does.
But it's wonderful.
If that's the original bar
and I bring this up a little,
a little, remember,
and this down a little,
I think that the new
bar has the same length.
You believe that?
No.
Some, yeah, but
what happened there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah,
this is a good example.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Sorry,
yeah, certainly bringing
that up tended to
make the bar shorter,
but then moving this down tended
to make it a little longer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Right
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Yeah, I think so.
See, that was the key.
We went at 90 degrees to five.
And by going at 90 degrees,
then the stretch in there
was only that one minus
cosine that was higher order.
That's the key.
Similarly, here,
all these-- So we're
avoiding stretching
by this trick.
So maybe this guy is
going down this same way.
And this guy is going
up that same way.
Yeah, because then that
bar is just translating,
and this bar is
translating and these two
are doing the same thing, which
I believe is not stretching.
Is this the answer that
maybe somebody already got?
And believed in?
Yeah.
So to answer your original
question, it wasn't obvious,
was it?
But I think that
is the right thing.
And actually, you could
create the A for this problem.
Well, it's a bit
large, 48 entries,
but because four of the bars
are horizontal or vertical,
you will have many, many,
many, zeroes in the A matrix.
It would be sort
of fun to create
the A matrix and then this.
So what is this displacement
that I believe in?
This u mechanism that
we've talked about.
Let's see, if I look at one
that was positive positive.
If I looked at node two, that
was positive over but down.
So horizontal but down.
If I look at node three,
that's positive positive.
Yeah, one and three
is hanging on.
And number four is like
number two, one and minus one.
I think that's the u
which should solve Au=0.
Yeah.
OK.
But that's a good example.
OK, so that's trusses.
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Thank you.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Oh, well, let's see.
That's a good question
and now I guess we're, ah.
Yeah well, the way I've
drawn it at 45 degrees, which
is what I wrote here,
then I did build in,
I did make that a forty--
I did make this 45 or 135
or something.
And 45.
To get that, if that
goes at 45 degrees,
then this had better
go at 135, right?
So that has to be a right angle.
If the support
was over here then
the angle that would have
gone off with was changed.
Yeah, so very good point,
that the numbers I've
written down on the picture
I drew required these angles
to be those nice numbers.
I hope you like these
trusses a little.
I mean, you get some freedom
to visualize a little.
Good, yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Maybe.
Let me see.
I thought you were
going to say, could I
have two and three go inwards
and one and four go outwards?
You don't like that.
I would go with that.
Is that any good?
Well, OK.
Yeah, linear
algebra spoke there.
It's a combination of
the other two, yes.
If we only got a
two-dimensional.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: That one.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK.
But let me-- When you
suggested one, I overwrote it.
Now, the one you suggested--
When you told me,
OK, bring these in, I thought,
OK, these have to go out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: They're not
allowed to change lengths,
so they can only swing
around these pin joints.
So the picture of the one that
I drew after your question
would be, these guys, this
guy, let me draw the square,
as it was.
And then these guys
came in a little.
These guys went out a little.
And we got this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: No, that's OK.
I think this is legitimate,
this is a legitimate one.
And that bar, every bar now is
doing the same kind of thing
that this one did.
This moved a little,
but this compensated
and kept the length the same.
Your question has led us
to another nifty mechanism.
It's good, a good
one to think about.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
It's movement
without stretching.
Movement without
stretching is the key, yes.
And then where
does collapse come?
So I use the word
collapse pretty freely.
So the word collapse
comes in because since it
can move without stretching
there's nothing controlling it,
it can move-- Well,
if we stayed linear,
then I could make all
those ten and the thing
would be even worse, of course.
The truth is that if I
made those even one or ten
I would be out of
the linear range.
These all should be
0.01's or something.
But linear we don't
know the difference.
OK, I'm glad you've
got that suggestion.
And now somebody correctly
says that this one
must be some combination
of that and what
was the first movement?
Oh, the upper two.
Which it must be.
Amazing, how many-- Put a few
bars up there and you got it.
Yeah.
And of course, by
the way, and don't
let me get too far
into this discussion,
but who is the artist,
actually is it Alexander Calder
who has, what are they called?
You know, they're-- What
was it called again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Well, he has those, that wasn't
the word I was thinking of.
But he's created these
trusses, like with lots
of bars and lots of nodes that
have some special property.
You know, they just, anyway.
It touches on art, actually
this theory of mechanisms.
Yeah it's really
quite interesting.
But then linear algebra
somehow tells you
just from these numbers how many
mechanisms you're looking for.
Which is pretty cool.
OK, open for more questions.
You probably haven't
looked ahead,
I mean today's
lecture was a-- I hope
and I left up there the
central topics for the lecture.
But I'm, I think,
correct that you haven't
started on those problems.
To know what to ask.
Let me ask you a question,
which was not in the lecture.
Suppose I wanted to
use finite differences.
It's a little bit like
the one on the quiz.
So on the quiz we had c,
equal ones, and then c=2.
And you knew c had
to be four by four,
so most people correctly got the
diagonal as one, one, two, two.
Just by sort of common sense.
But what would be
a finite difference
approximation to our equation?
So suppose I didn't
go to finite elements,
but instead I stayed with
finite differences, which
would be completely fine in
1-D, completely sensible.
How would you create a finite
difference thing for that?
Let me just bring down
a blank board and ask.
So you see the equation?
Let me write it again here.
So I want to replace this
equation with a varying-- that
has varying c(x).
Well, I won't worry
about the right side.
It's f.
What's my K matrix using
finite differences for this?
We're going to create
a finite element K
matrix by the weak
form, Galerkin trial
function, that route.
That's coming-- That's very
important, that's coming,
started today and it'll
be completed Friday.
But now suppose we were back
up to finite differences.
What would you take for
finite differences there?
When the c wasn't
there, what did we do?
Then we just had second
difference, right?
How did we get the
second difference?
It was a first difference
of a first difference.
I guess I would probably-- This
I would probably approximate
by (u_(i+1)-u_i) over delta x.
That would be that, and so
what should I put for c(x)?
What would you suggest?
c subscript i, so let's mark.
Here's i, and here's
i+1, and here's i-1.
We're going to end up with
those three guys involved.
So this takes this difference,
and then this one will take
that one, and then I'll also
have a u_i-u_(i-1) over delta
x.
And somehow that'll
be the difference
of these differences.
But now tell me
again, what would
be the really cool choice of c?
What's your instinct where
what value of c to take?
As sort of average.
I mean you could
take it just halfway.
I think I would take
c_(i+1/2) there.
Just as being sort of right.
And here I would take c_(i-1/2),
halfway along its interval.
And then the second difference
takes the difference of it.
So now I've got-- I think
that's what I would do.
That would be my typical,
one typical finite difference
equation.
Would be the
difference times its c
and I took its c
to be symmetric.
You could also have
taken, if you'd liked,
if you wanted to
stay at these points,
you could do twice as much
work and take, let me say,
or-- So either c_(i+1/2),
or you could average the c_i
and the c_(i+1) over two.
And both of those would
give you that extra accuracy
that you pick up from
sort of keeping symmetry
where you should.
So I think, I mean, this would
be the quicker one to put,
that one would be OK too.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: This was just
for your entertainment not,
not-- Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Ah,
when c was a step yes.
When c was a step.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: c_(i+1/2)
Probably the step-- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Let me ask you, what happens
in this equation when c jumps?
It jumped on the quiz.
But I didn't require you
to solve the differential
equation, only to create
the finite difference model,
to create the A transpose C A,
and most people did it fine.
But suppose c jumps.
I have some simple
right-hand side like one.
It's not a jump in
the right-hand side
I'm interested in.
It's a jump in c
from one to two.
So this is a topic that
the book does discuss
and maybe I might come back
to it in the ordinary lecture.
But, while it's in
front of us now,
the quiz was sort of intended
to help you with that.
How do I interpret this
equation when c has a jump?
Well, it's actually,
if you look at it
right there's no difficulty.
That equation is a combination
of this equation -dw/dx equals
the one.
And the equation of
c*du/dx equalling the w.
I split it out for
you in the last part,
Problem 4b in the quiz.
I really helped you to
say OK, take these two
separate equations.
And now you don't
really have a problem.
The equation for w, nothing
is out of the ordinary there.
Jump in c is not even seen.
So then you've got the w.
Now, you have the c in
it with its little jump.
But, so suppose I find w
from the first equation.
How do I find u?
I just divide by the c.
And integrate.
Yeah.
What I'm saying, let
me say it, clearly now.
If there's a jump in c,
that's not a bad thing.
Because the point is
there's no jump in c*u'.
c*du/dx doesn't
jump. w doesn't jump.
From a jump in c.
If c jumps, let it.
There's no jump in w, which
is the serious unknown.
There'll be a jump
in du/dx, and that
was that e thing that
you had on the quiz.
There'll be a jump in du/dx
to compensate the jump in c,
but w is good.
That's the message of--
So let me write that down.
Even if c jumps, w does not.
So my point is when
you're looking at w,
you're looking at
the right quantity.
And it deals, this is the
sort of general feature
that if you look at it
right it's not a problem.
If you look at it wrong and
try to write out that equation,
take the second
derivative of this is OK,
but then if you just try to
take the derivative of the jump,
you think, my God
there's a delta function
sitting in my equation,
what am I to do.
Don't do it.
That pair of equations
is no trouble.
Do you see that point?
That a jump in c is really OK.
c=0 wouldn't be so good, right?
If c went to zero then you
have got some problems here,
because if c is zero
here what's going on?
So your material should
have some stiffness,
some positive stiffness.
Zero stiffness
would be a problem.
Negative stiffness
would be really
a crazy material, where
you add more force
and it compresses on you.
OK so that was a point I could
make also in the lecture.
Other questions.
I hope you find these
review sessions--
They give a chance to
bring out more points.
Let me say a little bit
about Chapter 2 things
that we abandoned without
including in the lectures.
One very important thing
that we didn't touch
was the non-linear problems.
Where in the end you
have to solve a system
of non-linear equations.
We've only had linear
equations, Ku=f,
where we almost got to-- And
we've certainly found enough
to discuss there.
But how do you deal with
non-linear equations?
Well so that's
Section 2.6, I guess.
And the answer is Newton's
method, or some version,
there are many versions
of Newton's method.
So all I'm saying is
that's an important topic.
How to deal with
non-linear equations.
And the answer is usually some
variation of Newton's method.
Depending on how
many equations you've
got, how bad the non-linearity
is, and things like that.
It's a case where
coding is not so simple.
But important.
So that's one thing in
Chapter 2 that we've
passed, because really this
is where we want to be today.
Other topics,
questions of any kind?
Yes, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
This problem, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yes
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Well, OK.
Right, good question.
You're right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah, OK.
So now suppose that delta
of x was in-- delta of x-a,
the jump at a, was there.
What would change in there?
Well, the one would
change, right?
The one would now
be the delta of x-a.
So what am I seeing now?
What's the jump situation now?
Is there a jump in, does w jump
now from this delta function?
Yes.
It did not jump
from the jump in c.
That did not produce
us a jump in w.
Why not?
Because again, back to the jump
in c, you have a bar of copper
and you have a bar of steel.
And they have different c's.
But the force at that point,
when it's in equilibrium,
the bar's not
falling apart, right?
The force is the same from above
and below; equilibrium holds.
It's just that the force
involves a c_1 there,
and down here the force involves
a c_2 multiplying the du/dx,
and this stretching.
So the stretching
rule changes. du/dx,
the stretching factor will be
different in the two materials.
But the force won't be.
You really have to
keep straight what--
Now, you asked about
a delta function, OK.
So now if I hang a
delta function there,
that's like hanging a
point load at a point.
What happens at that point?
Well, we don't have
a problem with that.
Well, w jumps.
The force pulling up is
not the same as the force
pulling down because there's
this extra point load.
So the balance there
and the balance there,
those aren't equal.
There's a jump there because of
the point load being put there.
So that produces a jump
in w, but not a jump in u.
Not a jump in u, the bar
is still holding together.
And since time's
running out I don't
have to ask myself, or ask you,
about the worst possibility
that occurs to me,
which is suppose
they happen at the same place.
Suppose there's a jump
in c and a point load.
Do we want to face that,
what would happen there?
Suppose, a was the
place where this jumped.
Suppose the point load was here.
What's up there?
Well, maybe I will
able to do that.
OK, so I'm putting
the point load
at the place where the
copper and the steel meet.
Is w continuous?
Is the force the same
above and below that joint?
No.
Because there's these extra
terms from the weight.
And then once you
know the forces, then
above the bar you're solving
for u with one c, and then
below that point
with the other c.
So w has a plus and a minus
and c has a plus and a minus.
And you're solving this one,
let me make them minus plus.
So you're solving this
one in one bar, one metal.
And c plus and the w
plus in the other method.
So yeah, you can do it.
Shall I just repeat what
my overall message is?
w is the right thing to look at.
That combination c*du/dx is
the right thing to look at.
And it's what sits there.
In those parentheses.
OK, good, so that's
some review topics.
We really have a lot of fun
ahead now with finite elements.